when we think about truth and Justice
and what that actually means and what
we're actually exploring in this show
it's not static what Justice looks like
to you will not be what Justice looks
like to me I think we explore that
beautifully in season three do you have
a lead maybe can I come with I play EVA
Pierre High School principal where a
number of her students are being
trafficked over the course of the Season
layers are peeled back I need to do more
the way I was able to get into the
character is I lived it unfortunately
I've had 30 years to intimately
understand sexual violence against young
black and brown girls Eva is trying to
heal and make amends and prove to
herself in the world that she is a good
person I found my moments of justice and
my version of the truth I try to give
that to Eva
[Music]